good evening I'm here to present best
foreign language film the Academy is
trying something new this year because
we are an international show and because
there are over 1.2 billion people in
China they have asked me to briefly
speak about this category in Mandarin
Chinese luckily I speak it fluently one
quick note since my mother spoke German
to us while we were growing up my
Chinese has a very slight German accent
you got Vegas policy and since since
they may I give mine some nasai lateness
Justin's olive appendage
sheesh biking you bi remaining humanity
it in on salad I love Chinese well
regardless of what country they are from
movie speak to all of us through their
captivating images and their wonderful
stories contending for best foreign
language film tonight movies are from
Belgium Israel Poland Canada and Iran
and here they are from Belgium bullhead
directed by mikio our Roskam from israel
footnote directed by joseph cedar from
poland in darkness directed by Anne
Jessica Holland from Canada Maceo
deserve directed by philippe padieu from
iran a separation directed by Oscar Fadi
and the Oscar goes to a separation Iran
Oscar party
a separation is the first movie from
Iran to win the Academy Award
own language film
I would like to thank the Academy and
Sony Pictures Classics and my dear
friends Michael Barker and Tom donut
Salaam Bernardo mei-hua Sam Sammy Nam at
this time many onions all over the world
are watching us and I imagined them to
be very happy they are happy not just
because of an important award or a theme
or a fee maker but because at the time
and talk of war intimidation and
accretion is exchanged between
politicians the name of their country
Iran is spoken here through her glorious
culture reach an Asian culture that has
been hidden under the heavy dust of
politics I proudly offer this hour to
the people of my country the people who
respect all cultures and civilizations
and despise hostility and resentment
thank you so much